mesdames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur le commissaire mes chers
collègues la réforme des retraites telle
que proposée dans votre rapport monsieur
delevoye inquiète les femmes mères de
famille actuellement les mères de
famille valide 8,8 trimestre dans le
secteur privé par enfant né ou adopté et
quatre trimestres dans le public
il s'agit de ce que l'on appelle la
majoration de durée d'assurance la
réforme envisagée supprime les
dispositifs actuels pour les remplacer
par une majoration retraite de 5% pas
enfants des premiers enfants
cette bonification pourra éventuellement
être transféré au père ou partager avec
lui la retraite des femmes est
actuellement inférieur de 38 % à celle
des hommes
cela est en grande partie due à la
maternité qui conduit un grand nombre de
femmes à prendre du temps pour leurs
enfants a renoncé à une promotion à
prendre un temps partiel ou un congé
parental pour beaucoup de maires n'ayant
pas de carrière complète
l'attribution d'une retraite qui soit le
strict reflet de leur période d'activité
sera défavorable par rapport au système
actuel
il est particulièrement injuste de
bonifier la retraite d'un par an en
pourcentage en laissant les maires dont
les carrières sont incomplètes mais
aussi celles ayant de petits salaires il
serait particulièrement inéquitable que
la réforme des retraites accroissent
l'écart de niveau des retraites au
détriment des mères monsieur le
commissaire est ce que cette majoration
de 5 % se substituera à la majoration de
durée d'assurance pénalisant ainsi les
femmes ayant élevé plusieurs enfants
d'autre part est ce que cette loi aura
un effet rétroactif
en supprimant les droits acquis par les
femmes ayant eu des enfants avant
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme en
2025 pour vous répondre